le preguntó Cuál es la particularidad de
digamos la corrupción en Turquía si nos
pudiera poner algún ejemplo con algún
país por ejemplo de la región
latinoamericana o de otro país para que
nos hagamos un ejemplo en términos
relativos una idea
Bueno en realidad la corrupción es algo
que se puede medir en términos de su
percepción por parte de la ciudadanía
pero ese enfoque también ha sido
criticado por muchos investigadores de
la corrupción porque en realidad esa
percepción depende por ejemplo de muchos
factores culturales y es Generalmente
Así que la corrupción de bajo nivel es
más visible para pues la población
mientras la corrupción de altos
políticos es menos visible y Por ende
menos representado en
esos índices y en Turquía podemos
observar que
Más allá de la corrupción de
de la calle para decirlo así No desde
bajo nivel más allá de de ese de esa
corrupción uno puede observar que el
gobierno de erdoan se ha visto como
encima de la ley en general involucrado
en proyectos de
asuntos que parecen casi un culto de
personalidad Como por ejemplo la
construcción de un inmenso Palacio para
el presidente Turco no la así llamada
Casa Blanca
y otros asuntos y también el nepotismo
por ejemplo que el presidente Turco
promovió
familiares a posiciones de importancia
en su gobierno que en realidad
son asuntos que se han visto también en
la en la región latinoamericana pero
parecen parece una corrupción un poco
más drástica más masiva y más desde
arriba y Entonces tal vez es una mejor
comparación que simplemente un índice
numérico y Y si usted dice que la
corrupción en este caso quizás Es más
desde arriba Entonces esto significa que
un cambio en la jefatura del Estado
podría
conllevar una digamos una mejora de este
sistema corrupto que podría limpiarse
por decirse así lo que se suele decir
como manzanas podridas del sistema
podría ser podría ser también el nuevo
gobierno sería esencialmente una
coalición de partidos y agrupaciones que
debería legitimarse de nuevo con un con
un con una actitud mejor frente a
problemáticas como la corrupción al
mismo momento es posible que
el control sobre la burocracia y sobre
otras entidades del estado como por
ejemplo las fuerzas armadas se
debilitaría Así que también es posible
que el nuevo gobierno enfrentaría
ciertas problemas de
gobernabilidad sobre todo al principio
de su legislatura